at least 25 people have been detained in
a series of overnight raids across
Germany over a plot to overthrow the
state by force some 3 000 police
officers were involved in searches of
more than 130 properties Nationwide
authorities believe the suspects are
linked to a Nationwide far-right Network
among them are several former members of
the Armed Forces and at least one active
Soldier
we want this fast-moving story let's
bring in DW's political correspondent
Julius saudeli Julia what more can you
tell us about these raids and about the
suspects that have been detained
yeah this was a very big operation that
took place in 11 of Germany States but
also two people were arrested abroad one
in Italy one in Austria and we've seen
that 25 people have been arrested but
that there are a further 27 uh suspects
in the case suspected of also being part
of this uh what is being called a
terrorist Network and it is assumed that
this is one of the biggest
anti-terror operations in Germany since
World War II uh the accused and the
suspects are seen to have been part of a
terrorist Network that was seeking to
overthrow the Democratic order in
Germany and the center of this network
seems to be
an entrepreneur from the city of
Frankfurt in Germany who calls himself a
prince although it is only a symbolic uh
title but he owns a hunting lodge in
thirinja and he seems to have been the
man that was coordinating this network
and part of the network was apparently
also a former a member of the German
Parliament for the far-right afd party
who is currently an active judge in the
city of Berlin but also members of the
German Army and one member of the German
Special Forces
now the suspects apparently had a plan
to overthrow the German government by
force how realistic are these or were
these threats
well the network seems to have formed at
the latest in November 2021 so last year
and the investigations into the network
started in the early months of of this
year after a tip came from the
intelligence services in the state of
hessen especially regarding uh this uh
Prince Heinrich as he is called and it
seems like this network was actively
working to form almost like a shadow
cabinet and to arm itself to carry out
an armed attack against the bundestag
the German Parliament and actively
arrest politicians and then therefore
bring about a change in the government
order of of Germany basically carrying
out a coup and the group wanted to
change the the government of Germany
take power with the support of uh the
Russian Federation the prosecution has
said that the members of the network had
already tried to get in touch with the
representatives of Russia here in
Germany to try to facilitate this
process so we are talking of plants to
carry out a coup here
now the suspects are alleged members of
the so-called reisberger scene tell us
more about that movement
yeah rexburger means a citizen of the
Reich of the German Empire and this is a
group of people who believe that the
current Democratic order in Germany is
illegitimate that the Democratic order
that was established after the end of
World War II is illegitimate and that
the actual form of government that
should still be in place in Germany is
that of the German Empire and they have
often conflicts with authorities they
refuse to pay taxes and
estimates are that around uh 21
000 people are a member are members of
this network they have gotten closer to
the anti-coronavirus protest movements
that took place in the last few years
taking over these protests but also
merging with the conspiracy theorists
that are also part of this movement and
they are also somewhat close to the Q
Anon movement that is quite a
significant especially online and and it
is a a movement that has been also
watched by authorities and police forces
here in Germany
our political correspondent Julia
sardelli there thank you Julia